we need a code try uh seven
settle down captain lucky it's not gonna
be one number
god that's lazy writing i still got it
[Music]
welcome to your weekly ticket
marvel studios along with star producer
ryan reynolds have tapped sisters wendy
molino and lizzie molino lozlen of bob's
burgers fame
to pen the next deadpool movie
reportedly marvel has been meeting with
riders pitching their deadpool 3 ideas
for about a month
with the mollino sisters pitching the
perfect fit marvel wanted
while the film is still in the early
stages the hiring of the mollino sisters
marks the first major step
into getting the next deadpool film into
production although
no premise has been announced yet
deadpool 3 is the first of the trilogy
to be guided by marvel studios and its
president kevin feige officially
bringing the character
into the mcu the black panther sequel is
set to begin filming
next july of course plans to shoot in
march were pushed back following the
sudden
and tragic death of star chadwick
boseman mexican actor tenochuerta who
played in narcos mexico is in talks to
play one of the antagonists and is the
first new actor to be linked to the cast
leticia wright lupita nyong'o winston
duke and angela bassette are all
expected to return for the new feature
with reports indicating that wright's
character shuri
may take on a much more prominent role
and scottish filmmaker lynn ramsey will
direct an adaptation of stephen king's
the girl who loved tom gordon ramsay who
last directed the acclaimed thriller you
were never really here
also co-wrote the script alongside
christy hall who is the co-creator of
the netflix
series i am not okay with this the girl
who loved tom gordon follows a
nine-year-old girl who finds herself
lost in the woods after straying from
her arguing mother and brother
production is set to commence sometime
next year with village roadshow pictures
backing the project
it's thanksgiving week and while there's
plenty to look forward to
like the impending feasts the black
friday deals bonding with friends and
family
i think we can all agree the real win
here is getting to spend hours on the
couch watching some of our favorite
movies
whether you want a binge an actor's work
or a complete franchise
thanksgiving weekend is the perfect
weekend to dive deep into your watch
list
and this week we have a very special
guest comedian and host of the rotten
tomatoes
binge battle show mark ellis with some
ideas on what to binge over the holiday
weekend
oh kale oh i'm so excited that you're
here
i have missed you you look fantastic
and you look like it's time to fatten us
both up for thanksgiving let's brush
some turkey
absolutely stuffing gravy on everything
absolutely i mean we got to have
something to watch while we're like
letting all of the food sit
for multiple days and what we're gonna
watch while we're eating the leftovers
so since you're an expert on this what
is your favorite movie franchise to
binge watch
the grumpy old men two packets grumpy
old men
and grumpier old men now if you haven't
thought about these movies in a while
you've never heard of them walter
matthau and jack lemmon two
all-time great comedic actors from the
odd couple the original one
they reunited in the 90s for these two
films that
have them vying for the affections of
women that have them bickering at each
other over nonsense
and it's cold weather and kale that's
the other thing i want to do i want to
get into the holiday season i want to
ingratiate everybody into christmas
with some snowy movies grumpy old men
fits the bill they didn't make a third
one would that be grumpiest
they really dropped the ball by not
having grumpies what they did
do is walter matthew and jack lemmon
teamed up one more time for out to c
which was the two of them bickering on a
boat and so i think they were just like
you know what we're done
with the cold we want to go on a cruise
ship like every other old person just
get us to florida
get us on a boat and let's argue there
yeah at some point you just gotta be
like i gotta start doing this for fun
you got two movies down i assume my food
hangover is gonna last longer than that
and my maybe my actual hangover so what
else you got
if you are still up and maybe you put
the kitties to bed for this next film
franchise i'm going to get to because
again
i want to celebrate holidays i want to
celebrate food what better to do both
than
harold and kumar all three of them yeah
i'm going to white castle yeah i'm going
to gitmo and then you get harold and
kumar's christmas and that's gonna get
everybody i'm building bridges here kale
the kids are in bed they're not gonna
hear any of the weed jokes
they're gonna go right from celebrating
burgers which we all just had
turkey and then we're gonna go right
into the christmas season you see what i
did here yeah
i see it i see why you're uh you're a
specialist of this this is
i forgot there was three i knew there
was two people never
talk about their christmas movie because
it was in 3d in theaters and it's one of
the best usages of 3d that i've ever
seen
so much great comedy with stuff coming
at you including yes
occasionally a cloud of smoke and that's
where we'll leave it we live in
california
not everybody does it's smog it's a it's
a cloud of smoke it's just weather it's
a weather thing that's what it is
you have another one for us okay look if
you are still awake
after i gave you grumpy old men to watch
with a family hilton kumar to watch with
your buddies with the adults
then here's what's going to close out
because it still has a lot of comedic
value but also gets a little naughty
time
50 shades the franchise is available
folks if you need a closer for your
evening what better way if you're
watching harold and kumar you probably
are
giggling a lot for various reasons so go
ahead and put on 50 shades and watch the
most awkward relationship
of all time over one of the most
celebrated
trilogies in recent memory how many of
those are there
i think there's like three but there
might be nine i
i'm not really sure and then they start
to run into twilight for me so i can't
really tell them apart
and it's just it's a glob of movies that
i think you can just close your eyes
reach your hands and pull one out and
have some giggles until you fall asleep
or until the sun comes up i think you're
right on
on the money especially with sort of
like a guilty pleasure just kind of
chill
and like if you have any sort of
accessibility to like
have some fun with it you know what i
mean so yeah that's a great that's a
great choice
i just finished watching twilight and i
i don't know if i actually watched 50
shades of grey either
so treat yourself it's as long as you're
not taking out a notepad and taking
notes like oh this is how a relationship
should work
just enjoy the giggles nothing do not
take these movies seriously folks i'm
warning you right now this is not how to
approach women
this is not how men should act but if
you get in there and you watch it for
the train wreck it is
enjoy all right mark well thank you so
much for coming on i love having you on
man uh
i hope we see each other again soon
where can people find you uh you can
find me on all the social medias at mark
ellis live and check out the new podcast
that i co-host alongside jacqueline
coley rotten tomatoes
is wrong if you love a movie but it's
apparently rotten on the tomato meter we
talk about if you think a movie should
be rotten but it's fresh somehow
we talk about it we love to hear your
thoughts you can email us anytime rt is
wrong
gmail.com highly recommend it uh from
this side too
so all right thanks mark love you buddy
miss you happy holidays
available to watch in theaters croods a
new age
what the heck is that it's the end of
the world
well that's it for me i'm glad it's you
chunky
the croods need a new place to live so
the first prehistoric family sets off
into the world
in search of a safer place to call home
when they discover an idyllic walled in
paradise that meets all their needs
they think their problems are solved
except for one thing
another family already lives there the
betterments
when all seems lost a new threat will
propel both families on an
epic adventure outside the safety of the
wall one that will force them to embrace
their differences
draw strength from each other and forge
a future together
[Music]
and available to watch at home is buddy
games
all right boys here we go the buddy
games are back we're gonna play for 150
000 bucks after six lifelong friends
have a five year falling out they decide
to reunite and play the buddy games
a wild assortment of absurd physical and
mental challenges for a chance to win
150 000
in the process they'll heal old wounds
right past wrongs and figure out the
true meaning
of friendship all right that's it for
today but leave us a comment and let us
know what you'll be watching this week
i'm kale and i'll see you next time
[Music]